the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu ok great so a lot of effort
went into making this course and we hope
you've had fun it's been a lot of
support from Sony IBM toshiba a lot of
on-demand help from people at IBM and
Sony trying to debug problems even up to
the last minute so we're very thankful
for that and we hope in return that you
really enjoyed course and it was really
fun so looking forward to the course
evaluations so just want to tell you a
little bit about some opportunities
ahead I passed out these brochures for
the cell broadband engine challenge
beyond gaming and this is an IBM
sponsored event where you really can
compete in two different challenges and
one of them you can win really seriously
cool t-shirts that's actually lifted
directly from the online link so the
competition starts februari 5 at
midnight and you have to pass an online
quiz of which I expect all of you should
be able to pass and hopefully you will
compete and at least get a seriously
cool t-shirt the second challenge which
is potentially more interesting just
because there's a 10k grand prize
there's also 7k second prize and you
know some serious money for for at least
three or four prizes you can look at the
information the brochures according to
the information you'll find it requires
some serious coding skills on your part
but I certainly expect all of you to be
able to be a well primed at this point
especially since you've learned about
sell hands-on you've discovered all the
pitfalls on your own it would make for a
very good competition on your part there
are different categories sorry it's
three categories not for application
solutions so some of the things so many
people have done more application
oriented thing could fit or you can sort
of took what you've learned
apply to financial services you have
interest in that medical imaging
electronic design automation things that
I took operating systems I'm not sure if
that's particularly relevant to a lot of
people here I'm not sure if that's in
their interest area but programmability
so certainly the streaming framework
that that one of the software radio
projects tried to do would fit under
that some of the work that the ray
tracing team did in terms of coming up
with their own interface for graphics
could certainly fit so I I urge you to
sort of consider competing in these
there's probably a lot of fame and
fortune to be had here so we had our own
competition and what you're going to get
are some seriously cool trophies since
we don't have t-shirts so Mary was very
could've had t-shirts I do you want to
compete with IBM directly so for the
winning team you will get this seriously
awesomely looking trophy which has a
little imprint on the front that says
first place 6.1 89 and you're also going
to get a hundred fifty dollar gift
certificates i think we announced this
at the beginning of the course i'm also
working with people at IBM on arranging
and one day trip to IBM TJ watson
research center for the winning team to
sort of present their winning project do
a demo and then meet with people IBM was
sort of doing really cool interesting
research and it should be a fun day and
certainly people iBM has very have been
very excited about hearing what's going
on in this project in this class and so
we good fun opportunity i think all
around ok so I'm going to work my way up
to the first prize I think in terms of
the complexity of this the project
handled certainly speech into system
probably took on the most complex
certainly in terms of software that they
used and maybe that bog them down a
little so there's probably something to
be said in terms of starting from
scratch versus taking complex
infrastructure and re-engineering it for
parallelism I think you've discovered
firsthand you know how hard that really
is and this is you know a big problem
for parallel computing there's a lot of
legacy
software out there that eventually might
have to report it to parallel
architectures how do you do it you know
you pointed out code is not well
documented tools are lacking so what do
you do so you've stumbled on really
seriously important problem facing a lot
of people in industry the most
synchronization issues we believe the
that the guys who are doing the battery
simulations and modeling of chemical
reactions certainly ran into a lot of
synchronization issues which is because
of the dependent nature of the
computation the next up on the list
would be for the most parallel
programming challenges so not only that
they run into issues with
synchronization but certainly discovered
problems with races and I think they're
the only team will successfully hung the
PlayStation 3 several times and required
a reboot quite a few times okay so next
best effort wards these guys should
really be highlighted because they were
largely on their own is that true yeah
and that's not true and there was
certainly a a lot of people who were
pressed by the global illumination stuff
yesterday and sort of mentioned that and
what I'm hoping to do is take the judges
feedback and sort of summarize that for
each team so you can have some
constructive criticism back that might
be helpful Marco dynamic simulation work
that you heard about today I think
certainly valiant effort on his part as
well the most complete project I think
it would probably be back em and tutors
project I think in terms of scope it was
well defined in terms of what they
actually completed I think they came out
with a really cool game my money was on
them all along to actually win the first
prize but i think the ray tracing team
actually blew everybody away with their
demo and i think of a clear winner they
had really a tackle sort of the
parallelization december izing they had
really cool frame buffer demos that I
figure out how to actually write to the
frame buffer and do that simulation
there are due to graphics rendering and
I think some mumbling about a real cool
demo that they've gotten working
overnight so we'll try to set that up
over and start when we
we have pizza and you guys can take a
look at that so with that I will hand
out the certificates and the awards
offline but you've at this point Ben
sulfide and the cake is in the back says
congratulations on your cell ification
so that's right so thanks a lot for
taking the course I think we've learned
a lot as instructors I'm hoping to do
this again with some on next year next I
ap and maybe eventually turn into
regular semester course I think there's
a lot of things we can do better and
hopefully you've told us some ideas of
how to do that so with that thanks and
start enjoying cake back